welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2 just
snuck in a star wars movie easter egg i
don't think any of us expected to see
again
snoke or at least a mr burns painting
tank boy who looks a lot like snoke
among a row of creepy humanoid test
subjects in an
imperial lab supposed hopeful recipients
of baby oda's midichlorian rich blood
the rise of skywalker revealed snoke was
a genetic strand cast somewhere in the
pipeline toward resurrecting darth
sidious ember palpatine
but now this episode of the mandalorian
might have just confirmed how exactly
snoke fit into that timeline which also
tells us a lot more about the first
order
now the uh cynical reality is that snoke
was a missed opportunity caught in the
crossfire of a studio and directors not
really on the same page of who they
intended the ultimate villain of the
force awakens the last jedi and the rise
of skywalker to be
but now dave baloney and john favreau
are swooping in to say
don't worry us and our little internet
breaker are gonna explain who the hell
snoke was
and no he wasn't that guy in the genes
okay let us back up to remember how
snoke was first introduced to us
in the force awakens snoke was the force
sensitive ruler of the first order an
emperor style
hologram voiced mocap by andy circus
snoke's origins were initially intended
to be mysterious
hailing from the unknown regions and
worming his way up the ranks of the
first order bypassing first order
founders grand admiral ray sloane
and general brendell hux father to
armitage hux the first order general who
committed the galaxy's worst war crimes
but then subverted his whole life's work
by becoming a spy for the resistance
i'm the spy what anyway snoke oversaw
the first order's construction of
starkiller base on ilum and recruitment
of child soldiers like finn
and during that time he reached out to
ben solo with the force
encouraging the young man's
rebelliousness and independence so that
ben
would eventually turn on luke skywalker
and burn down luke's attempt to rebuild
the jedi order but
then when the last jedi came out we got
to know a different side to snoke
his weird love of finery golden robes
sith jewelry and we got to see a lot of
his actual freaky anatomy
he's really tall and that split in his
head the companion book actually
suggested the scar was
caused by a wound he suffered when he
was younger but
none of this backstory seemed to matter
though because kylo ren betrayed snoke
he split him in half
and he proclaimed himself the new
supreme leader of the first order
but then in the opening minutes of the
rise of skywalker further redefined
snoke's backstory
establishing him as a clone strand cast
one of
many copies incubated by palpatine's
scientists working on
exigal this group is called the sith
eternal
a cult of religious fanatics using gene
splicing
to preserve darth sidious and to develop
a new host body for him to live once
more they were never successful with one
of those failed tests including
palpatine's
strand cast son as kylo ren arrived at
exigal at the beginning of the movie the
ghostly voice of palpatine explained it
this way
snoke trained you well
i killed snoke i'll kill you
my boy i made
smoke i have been every
voice you have ever heard inside your
head
so essentially the voice of his
grandfather vader
kylo would pray to in the force awakens
and the voice of snoke that lured him
away from luke and taught him in the
first order according to palpatine the
rise of skywalker that was all
him why would palpatine go to all this
trouble well i mean i guess he could say
that if he were to approach young ben
solo as
himself that that you know jedi trainee
might immediately balk and shut him out
but by approaching him as his morally
clouded grandfather figure or
as a completely new stranger he could
use that new face
to better manipulate ben kind of like
how the greatest trick the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world he
didn't exist
and or that he was darth vader but what
new things have we learned about snoke
from this episode of the mandalorian but
uh before i continue i want to thank
ray khan for sponsoring this video so
raycon earbuds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing as
other top audio brands that you know
check it out they
stay in my ear even if i need to jerk my
head around to see if
it's a bird or a plane or a superman in
the sky not
losing these things see i wear these
raycon e25s while i'm working around the
house a long battery life is really
helpful when i'm five episodes deep in a
true crime podcast or just really
blasting some music
while i'm making a grilled cheese
because i like to blast while i make
grilled cheese but i don't want to force
my norah jones on anyone else with an
earshot
recons make a great holiday gift because
it's something your loved ones can use
every day for work or play at home or on
the go i have a set of their e25s and i
love them they have six hours of play
time seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit
now is the time to get your best prices
of the year on raycons but hurry this
offer is available for a limited time
only all you gotta do is just go to
buyrecon.com
new rockstars just click on the link in
the description box to get
20 off your recon purchase now as i was
saying when it comes to snoke's new
origin this episode of the mandalorian
suggests that the genetic experiments
that produce
cloned snokes did not begin on hexagonal
that they were actually part of an
experiment that dated back
years earlier around the time of the
mandalorian when
remnants of the empire and scientists
linked to the cloning facility on camino
attempted to harvest midichlorian rich
blood from donors
in order to inject into these strand
casts cloned bodies
and apparently all these attempts failed
but it's a start
the clearest close-up we got was this
test subject that looks a lot like snoke
now yes it would be odd for this subject
who already had the split in his head
when the companion book suggested snoke
got it as a scar as an injury but the
question remains
what led to the future successful trial
of snoke did a force-sensitive
midichlorian rich donor give his or her
life to make that happen
the child ahsoka tano maybe other jedi
figures like ezra bridger
and how do we reconcile this with the
identity we came to know as snoke
the voice of andy serkis and the owner
of we presume many leather-bound books
who was that was it andy circus and his
mocap suit actually being voiced in
mocapped by palpatine
i think we can surmise that snoke was an
independent identity
a strand cast created for the original
intent to host palpatine's spirit but
even after they created a successful
force-sensitive host body that was
alive palpatine's consciousness didn't
take it was not compatible for whatever
reason so instead palpatine constructed
a new identity in the body of snoke one
that he can control an identity that
would never know its true purpose
but one that could run the first order
and recruit ben solo doing all this as a
proxy for
sidious all while sidious's sith eternal
scientists kev spleison
and splicen until they got something
closer to a body that resembled sidious
original form so that they could pick up
with the final order after kylo ren
inevitably overthrew snoke so what got
them
there with like palpatine 2.0 beyond the
snow coast body
well i think that's what this season the
mandalorian is going to explore further
maybe the future of this tank boy on
navarro will explain
the different process that resulted in
palpatine 2.0 a difference that could
have been as simple as
baby yoda's blood snoke could have been
formed by splicing dna from donors like
that
but maybe that's as far as they could
get with that line of testing whereas
palpatine reformed with those scientists
using
slightly different means different
donors maybe even they found his broken
corpse recovered from that second death
star ruin
and yes i think mob gideon's group could
be the origins of that the origins of
the sith eternal the final order now i
used to think he could have been the
origins of the first order but
if the first order was genuinely
oblivious to their connection to
palpatine
i think moff gideon must be part of the
faction that is aware of the palpatine
connection now i guess the one thing to
keep in mind with that is the sith
eternal seemed to be a group of like
hooded cultists
interested in the sith doctrine of darth
sidious whereas moff gideon appears to
be a military officer more loyal to the
empire in the military might that
palpatine's emperor identity represented
but on the other hand gideon does wield
the dark saber which
could tell us he is interested in the
ways of the sith and the jedi
deeper than the military superiority
they help secure we should also accept
the possibility that mob gideon might
just have his own agenda maybe a
restoration of imperial military power
and that's it and that he is just being
used as a pawn by darker forces like the
sith eternal and palpatine in ways that
he doesn't fully appreciate and maybe
he'll just be cast aside when time is
right but the bottom line is that
snoke's story is going to be
more involved with star wars history
than you know exigal tub
bastard his rise happened way earlier in
the transition between the empire in the
first order his rule was a lot more
complicated than mere
palpa puppet and his death was yeah more
meaningful than his unflattering open
casket pukefest would have you believe
and if you want to help support this
channel you can buy shirts like the one
i'm wearing
at our official merch store new
rockstarsmerch.com it's filled with fun
nerdy designs and shirts and hoodies
masks subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars thank you
for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you